WELCOME TO FOX SQUARE IN MIDTOWN
MANHATTAN, HOME OF AMERICA'S
ELECTION HEADQUARTERS ON THE EVE
OF THE HISTORIC MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
WE HAVE A JAM-PACKED HOUR AHEAD
BUT FIRST.
FOX NEWS ALERT.
IN THE FINAL HOURS BEFORE VOTERS
HEAD TO THE POLLS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HITTING THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL HARDER THAN EVER
AS HE TRIES TO TIP KEY TOSS
ABRASIVES WITH A FLURRY OF
RALLIES.
IN CLEVELAND THE PRESIDENT FIRED
UP THE CROWD.
>> EVERYTHING WE HAVE CREATED
AND ACHIEVED IS AT STAKE ON
ELECTION DAY, IT IS.
IF THE RADICAL DEMOCRATS TAKE
POWER, THEY WILL TAKE A WRECKING
BALL TO OUR ECONOMY, A VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS IS A VOTE TO
CONTINUE OUR EXTRAORDINARY
PROSPERITY, OUR EXTRAORDINARY
JOURNEY TOGETHER.
A VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS IS A VOTE
TO BRING THIS ECONOMIC BOOM
CRASHING TO A SUDDEN HALT.
THE DEMOCRAT AGENDA IS A
SOCIALIST NIGHTMARE FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATIC BIG GUNS
COMING UP TO TRY TO STOP TRUMP.
BARACK OBAMA GOING AFTER THE
PRESIDENT AND THE G.O.P.
>> AMERICA IS AT A CROSSROADS.
THE HEALTH CARE OF MILLIONS IS
ON THE BALLOT.
A FAIR SHAKE FOR WORKING
FAMILIES IS ON THE BALLOT.
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
CHARACTER OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: FORMER NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG DISHING
OUT MILLIONS ON A NEW CAMPAIGN
ADD BACKING DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES.
>> WE EXPECT TO BE CALLED TO A
HIGHER PURPOSE.
WE EXPECT TO WORK TOGETHER.
I DON'T HEAR THAT CALL COMING
FROM WASHINGTON THESE DAYS.
DO YOU?
IN FACT, I HEAR THE OPPOSITE.
SHOUTING AND HISTORY OF
SENSITIVE CALM REASONING.
POINTED FINGERS AND SET OF OPEN
HANDS.
DIVISION INCENTIVE UNITY.
WE MUST SEND A SIGNAL TO
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON THAT
THEY HAVE FAILED TO LEAD, FAILED
TO FIND SOLUTIONS AND FAILED TO
BRING US TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHY I'M VOTING
DEMOCRATIC.
>> Jesse: OKAY, MARTHA,
WELCOME TO "THE FIVE."
>> Martha: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
>> Jesse: THE CLOSING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE HEALTH CARE
AND TRUMP IS DIVISIVE AND RACIST
AND THAT REPUBLICAN CLOSING
MESSAGE SEEMS TO BE IMMIGRATION,
THE ECONOMY, AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE UNHINGED.
ANY SIDES MAKING ANY TRACTION DO
YOU THINK?
>> Martha: WE ARE SEEING THE
POLLS NARROW.
IT'S JUST PLUS THREE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE LATEST READ OF
HOW THIS IS GOING TO GO.
I THINK WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT POLLING IN RECENT YEARS,
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THIS
WHOLE THING SHAKES OUT BUT IN
TERMS OF THE MESSAGES, I CAN'T
HELP BUT FEEL THEY KIND OF
SCRAMBLED TO THEM IN THE FINAL
WEEKS.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WERE
LACKING A COHESIVE MESSAGE OTHER
THAN RESISTANCE WHICH CLEARLY
HAS BEEN THEIR MAIN MOJO FOR THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN HAVING
THIS SCHIZOPHRENIC REACTION TO
IT WHERE THEY THINK THEY SHOULD
BE.
FOLKS LIKE PAUL RYAN THINK THEY
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON THE
ECONOMY.
IT'S A PRETTY EASY ARGUMENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE MORE FOR
THE JUGULAR WITH IMMIGRATION IN
THE CARAVAN, HE IS BETTING IT'S
GOING TO HELP FOLKS ALONG THE
WAY AND HE'S PROBABLY BETTING
THAT'S ULTIMATELY GOING TO HELP
HIM.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS BRINGING OUT
THE BIG GUNS?
BARACK OBAMA, JOE BIDEN,
MAYOR BLOOMBERG DROPPING
MILLIONS IN THE LAST WEEK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S GOOD
NEWS FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
ESPECIALLY BLOOMBERG IS A FORMER
REPUBLICAN.
PEOPLE HAVE A CLEAR SENSE
SOMETHING IS WRONG IF YOU GET
BLOOMBERG ABSOLUTELY SAYING THE
MESSAGE THAT COMES FROM THIS
WHITE HOUSE IS ONE OF DIVISION,
HATEFULNESS, FINGER-POINTING, AS
YOU SAW IN THE AD.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT THIS PICKS
UP ON SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW IN THE POLLS
WHICH IS THE PLURALITY OF
VOTERS.
40% SAY THEY WANT TO SEND A
MESSAGE WITH THEIR VOTE TOMORROW
TO OPPOSE DONALD TRUMP, 41% SAY
THEY WANT THEIR VOTE TO PUT MORE
DEMOCRATS IN POSITIONS TO BE A
CHECK ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I ALSO THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THE ADVERTISING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN IS
UTILIZED, THE ONE ABOUT THE
CARAVAN IN PARTICULAR, THE ONE
THAT HAD A MAN WHO BEEN ACCUSED
OF KILLING PEOPLE AS A
CENTERPIECE AND SOMEHOW
REPRESENTATIVE OF EVERYONE IN
THE CARAVAN, YOU     YOU HAVE SE
THE CARAVAN, YOU     YOU HAVE SN
PEOPLE PULLED OUT BECAUSE IT'S A
RACIST AD.
FOR THE MOST PART, DEMOCRATS
HAVE RUN ON THE ISSUES,
ESPECIALLY HEALTH CARE.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT'S
ABOUT WHO WE ARE, AS YOU HEARD
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA SAY, IT'S
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS AMERICANS,
AND WHO DO WE WANT TO BE?
OUR CHARACTER.
>> Jesse: DEFINITELY BRINGING
UP CHARACTER IN THE LATE HOURS
OF THE CAMPAIGN.
DANA, JUAN SAID YOU CAN GET A
READ ON WHAT PEOPLE THINK.
I'M NOT SO SURE.
I THINK WE HAVE NATE SILVER,
FAMOUS POLITICAL PROGNOSTICATOR,
GIVING A VERY WIDE STRETCH OF
POSSIBILITIES ABOUT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN TUESDAY.
LET'S LISTEN TO HIM.
>> OUR RANGE WHICH COVERS 80% OF
OUTCOMES GOES FROM ABOUT 15
DEMOCRATIC PICKUPS ALL THE WAY
TO THE LOW-TO-MID 50s.
MOST OF THOSE ARE ABOVE 23 WHICH
IS HOW MANY SEATS THEY WOULD
NEED TO TAKE THE HOUSE BUT NO
ONE SHOULD BE SURPRISED IF THEY
ONLY WIN 19 SEATS AND NO ONE
SHOULD BE SURPRISED IF THEY WIN
51 SEATS.
THOSE ARE EXTREMELY POSSIBLE.
>> Jesse: IT'S LIKE THE
WEATHERMAN.
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE 80 AND
SUNNY BUT IT'S A POSSIBILITY
COULD BE COLD AND RAINY.
>> Dana: I THINK IT'S EASIER
TO PREDICT THE WEATHER THAN
ELECTION OUTCOMES.
EVEN IF THE EXTREMES, LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS HOLD THE HOUSE OR
THE DEMOCRATS WE FIT WITH 50
SEATS, BOTH OF THOSE, THERE'S A
CHANCE, SMALLER CHANCES,
PROBABLY GOING TO BE SOMETHING
IN BETWEEN, I DO THINK THAT THE
GUBERNATORIAL RACES ARE SUPER
IMPORTANT.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE DOMINATED
IN THE STATES FOR SO LONG, LIKE
MAYBE 12 YEARS.
POLITICS CYCLE.
LOOKS LIKE THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO LOSE SEVERAL
GOVERNORSHIPS, AND THE ONES TO
REALLY WATCH I THINK, IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REELECTION, FLORIDA AND OHIO.
2020 YOU DO THE CENSUS AND
REDISTRICTING AND IT WILL HAVE A
BIG IMPACT.
>> Jesse: GREG, ONE DAY TO GO.
YOU LOOK VERY EXCITED.
>> Greg: I AM THRILLED AND
COLD.
I FEEL LIKE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CRAMMING FOR A FINAL.
THEY ARE HOPPED UP ON RITALIN
AND COFFEE.
ECONOMIC BOOM, GDP, WAGES, JOBS,
ALL THOSE THINGS, ALMOST THE
DESTRUCTION OF ISIS.
IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME.
PROGRESS WITH NORTH KOREA.
WE ARE SEEING PROGRESS ON TRADE.
WE ARE SEEING TWO JUSTICES ON
THE SUPREME COURT, KEYSTONE.
WE HAVE FORGOTTEN ABOUT
KEYSTONE.
WE ARE REBUILDING THE MILITARY.
THERE IS CONSUMER CONFIDENCE,
OPTIMISM, WORKER PRODUCTIVITY.
ANY ONE OF THESE SINGULARLY AS
AN ACHIEVEMENT TO SOMETHING YOU
CAN RUN ON.
THE PROBLEM WITH TRUMP AS HE HAS
TOO MANY GOOD THINGS.
ALL THAT THE DEMS HAVE HIS HATE.
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF HATE.
THEY DON'T JUST HATE TRUMP.
THEY HATE EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTS
TRUMP, AND THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER WHEN YOU GO TO THE
POLLS.
THEY ACTUALLY DESPISE YOU.
IT'S KIND OF SAD.
IN A WEIRD WAY, IT'S A TRIBUTE
TO TRUMP.
HE IS LIKE A SUPER VILLAIN AND
HE IS BRINGING OUT BLOOMBERG,
OBAMA, BIDEN, CELEBRITIES.
THEY ARE LIKE THE SUPER FRIENDS.
THEY HAVE TO GET TOGETHER TO
FIGHT THIS ONE GUY.
HE'S BASICALLY, I DON'T KNOW,
LEX LUTHER AND THEY ARE ALL
ROBIN.
>> Jesse: WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT
NOW WHEN THEY HAVE TO BRING IN
SO MANY HEAVY HITTERS, A
PRESIDENT WHO JUST LEFT OFFICE
TWO YEARS AGO COMING AND
CAMPAIGNING THIS AGGRESSIVELY
AND THIS PARTISAN LAY AGAINST
HIS SUCCESSOR.
NOT NECESSARILY UNSEEMLY BUT
IT'S NEVER REALLY HAPPENED TO
THIS EXTENT.
DOES THAT MEAN THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SO THREATENED THAT THEY HAVE TO
COME IN WITH THE HEAVY ARTILLERY
THIS LATE?
>> Juan: HE HAS THE BULLY
PULPIT.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
HE CAN DO THINGS LIKE SEND
TROOPS TO THE BORDER FOR NO
REASON.
HE CAN MAKE AN ISSUE OUT OF NO
ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE CARAVAN.
IT'S A THREAT, IT'S AN INVASION,
PULL THE CHILDREN IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S MADNESS.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS
THE NUMBER OF TOP DEMOCRATS
WILLING TO STEP OUT IN AN
UNORTHODOX FASHION BECAUSE THEY
SEE THIS AS A CRITICAL MOMENT.
I NOTICED IN A LOCKED OF ADS,
BOTH ON THE REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION IN OUR
LIFETIME.
>> Greg: THEY DON'T HAVE A
MESSAGE OTHER THAN WE HATE
TRUMP.
>> Juan: THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: IF THEY DON'T GET A
BLUE WAVE, THEY ARE GOING TO
BLAME THE WHITE RUSSIAN.